hello everyone and welcome to the Daily
climate show coming up
another year of record heat for our
oceans as our seas register their
hottest ever temperatures
or Riot police move in to clear
protesters from the German Village due
to be demolished to make way for a coma
how the evolution may take 23 million
years to replace Madagascar's mammals in
danger of extinction
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now with our oceans absorbing
more than 90 percent of excess heat
traps by greenhouse gas emissions they
serve as an undeniable indicator of
climate change so warmer oceans also
create more extreme weather leading to
Stronger hurricanes heavier rain and
flooding which makes it all the more
concerning that according to a new
report last year saw ocean temperatures
rise to their highest ever level well
the heat currently puts into the world's
oceans is the equivalent to about seven
Hiroshima atomic bombs of energy every
second that's astonishing while the
amount of extra heat absorbed by oceans
in 2022 compared to the previous year
was the equivalent to that produced by
320 billion hair dryers that's every
person on Earth running 40 hairdryers
all day every day level records at date
back to 1958 so a Relentless rise in
ocean temperature with an acceleration
in warming since 1990 it's extraordinary
well Simon boxel is a lecturer in
oceanography at the University of
southampton's national oceanography
Center Simon thanks for joining us on
the daily climate show
hello Leah good afternoon so while I was
talking there it's quite Stark I mean
what does this mean in real terms for me
and you trying to navigate our world and
the climate change around us
I think first of all the numbers are so
huge they're almost impossible to
understand you know the numbers actually
show that over the last 40 years you've
seen there's something like a a 200 uh
Zeta dual increase in energy
um putting that another way it takes a
lot more to heat up a bucket of water
than it does say a bucket of air and if
you put that energy into the atmosphere
rather than the ocean you'd increase the
temperature of the atmosphere by 100
degrees Celsius that gives you an idea
of how much energy we're talking about
and that energy is absorbed in the
surface 2000 meters of the water so it's
it's distributed nicely through that
layer but it's a huge amount of energy
and it's it's building up still and it's
going to keep building up for the
foreseeable future
and we we saw earlier this week Simon
didn't we with the news that the ozone
layer will eventually start to repair
itself and in in this context is there
any way of reversing what's happening
with the ocean's temperatures it can
happen but it's going to take time
um and to start we've got to stop the
climate change we stop need to stop that
global warming happening and even then
it's going to take decades if not
centrips for the oceans to settle back
down again so we're looking at a
long-term change and of course in the
meantime we're seeing our ice caps
melting quite rapidly we're seeing
extreme weather that sort of warm water
is driving stronger hurricanes is
driving more extreme weather you know we
are seeing these long droughts these
long periods of rainfall we've seen huge
amounts of flooding at the moment in
Britain for example uh and you know that
is the shape of things to come and this
last year has been the hottest on record
particularly for our oceans and Simon
lastly and briefly I I suppose one way
of reversing what's happening is
reaching those net zero emissions are
you hopeful that something can be done
to do that
I think we've got some problems to come
but I think you know we are heading the
right direction I'm a born Optimist
rather than a pessimist
um and I think you know people are now
aware particularly with Rising Energy
prices the energy is not only expensive
and valuable but also by preserving
energy we preserve the planet so we're
heading in the right direction but it
still needs a lot of political
initiative to take this forward and to
get to that Net Zero if we can love it
Optimus there Simon boxel thank you very
much for talking to us on the daily
climate show now in some more positive
news Britain had its Best Day Ever for
wind power yesterday with 21
620 megawatts of electricity are
generated by turbines around the country
now the previous record was only set 12
days ago that's according to the
National Grid so now let's take a look
at our data dashboard and let's just
take a look at Renewables for a second
and we're generating over roughly 58 of
electricity and that was made up mostly
uh by wind in the vast majority which is
great news
now octopus energy is to offer solar
panels batteries and heat pumps in a bid
to create ten thousand zero build homes
by 2030. now the energy provisor is
hoping to help customers save up to 90
percent on their electricity bills
during the cost of living crisis now
octopus will now install domestic solar
panels alongside their existing offering
of electric car chargers and air source
heat pumps and smart meters
now despite the recent rainfall
households are being urged to save water
this winter in a bid to avoid a repeat
of the widespread hose pipe bands of
last summer now some parts of the
country still remain at risk of severe
drought later this year now the average
person uses 152 liters of water every
day but polling for water UK found that
two-thirds of people thought their
entire household used less than 70
liters and that's enough for a five
minute shower
now the EU ban on crude oil imports from
Russia and the oil price cap are costing
Russia an estimated 160 million euros a
day that's a figure that's expected to
rise by the way to 280 million euros a
day by next month now the center for
research on energy and clean air found
Russia's earnings fell 17 last month to
the lowest level since the invasion of
Ukraine but it's fuel exports are still
currently worth
640 million euros per day
Now new research suggests it may take
around 23 million years for evolution to
replace Madagascar's endangered animals
if they become extinct now many of the
African Islands unique species are
threatened with Extinction this is due
to human influences of course such as
hunting deforestation and climate change
now Evolution and the arriving of new
species from other regions May
compensate for these extinctions
according to the experts but it will
take a very long time
now yesterday we brought you the news of
the German courts had rejected an
attempt by climate activists to remain
in an abandoned Village due to be
cleared so a huge open cast coal mine
can be expanded in a move the rwe Energy
company says it will help energy
security well it didn't take long for
events to or move on and write police
today entered the village of luxurath
near cologne and began removing
protesters or carsten Smith who's a
climate and energy expert with
Greenpeace Germany joins us now live
from Luxor at Carson thank you very much
for joining us today just give us a
sense of what's been happening because
we know Wright police moved in earlier
today didn't they
yeah right the police started to evict
with Sarat today in the morning and
hundreds of climate activists are
defending the village they build up
houses in the village they built up
solar energy and they are now defending
this Village
against the police and against rwe who
wants to dig out the coal under
Etc and carlston the Energy company you
mentioned there rwe they're saying along
with the government you know we need to
mine in this Village because it's energy
security for the future of Germany but
what do you and other people there feel
this is all about
no it's it's about the cold under
literature art and if you dig out this
coal Germany will never fulfill the
commitments from the police agreement
and about it's not about climate and
energy security because you can reach
the coal Under The Village Loops are out
in three years at the earliest so it's
not true you don't need the coral if you
pick out the coal you never reach the
climate goal and it has nothing to do
with energy security
so you believe that this mining under
lots of Earth will actually derail that
1.5 degrees commitment
yes Germany can never
reach the 1.5 limit
if they dig out for coal Germany and
especially the company rwe is addicted
to coal and that's our problem and it
was a really dirty deal between the
economic Ministry Minister Albert habeck
and the energy companies rwe which is uh
really a disaster for the climate Okay
carsten Smith thank you very much for
your time
um and just enough time to tell you
about the climate Show with Tom heat
well it's back the first show of 2023
and it'll be taking us deep into the
Soggy Woodlands of Dartmoor and learning
that they're actually fragments of great
swathes of rainforests that once covered
much of Western Britain you can watch it
at 3 30 in the afternoon or 7 30 in the
evening that's Saturday and Sunday don't
miss it and if there's something you
want to know about climate change or the
environment scan the QR code on your
screen now you can send us a question
and we'll do our best to answer it on
Tom's show this week